bonjour je suis venu vous parler de
l'université et de répondre à la
question l'université est elle menacée
d'être détruite par les work
sans doute avez vous entendu parler des
web des terribles maux qui menacerait
l'université surtout les sciences
humaines et sociales mais curieusement
on en a pas on en avait pas personne
n'avait entendu parler il ya un an à
peine on nous parlait plutôt des sochaux
justice wires les socios justice wires
10 et on détruisait l'université surtout
les sciences humaines et sociales
et puis en france on disait que c'était
les islamo gauchistes qui détruisent l
université et puis pour le président
vladimir poutine et pour le pape
françois c'est plutôt la can sur lequel
turquie est le problème parole d'expert
sans doute ce qui est bizarre c'est
qu'en fait à chaque année on change de
monstres il ya toujours un nouveau mons
qui détruit l'université mais moi je
suis prof à l'université et curieusement
d'année en année d'université toujours
là
on comprend donc bien qu'en fait ces
mots sont des mots piégée ce sont des
mots qu'on invente un peu comme des
épouvantails qu'on agite pour nous faire
peur et on en en réinvente à chaque
année pour entretenir cet esprit de
panique mais en réalité les ennemis
qu'on désigne ainsi sont toujours les
mêmes ce sont les féministes ou les
études de genre et les anti racistes ou
les études sur le récit sous solaris et
donc
je jeu en tant qu' en tant qu' en tant
qu homme blanc de 50 ans et plus et
dayraut sexuelle vous comprenez que je
devrais que le premier me sentir menacé
le premier à peine cuit mais pourtant je
suis juste blasé pourquoi est-ce que je
suis blasé parce qu'en fait c'était
depuis que j'ai 20 ans donc depuis plus
de trente ans qu'on entend ce discours
je suis rentrée l'université de montréal
en science politique en 1985 et se faire
le début des années 90 qu'on a commencé
à entendre parler de la tyrannie de la
political correctness où la censure de
la rectitude politique et au début je
comprenais absolument pas de ce nombre
ce dont il était question
ce qui m'avait surtout marqué dans les
dernières années c'était qu'un jeune
homme était entré à polytechnique prêt
d'ici à l'école polytechnique près d'ici
armé d'un fusil semi-automatique qu'il
avait déclaré qu'il détestait les
féministes et qu'il avait abattu 14
femmes un attentant de cynisme véritable
carnage une boucherie et puis le mur de
berlin est tombé et il entraînait avec
lui l'ensemble du blog l'est et de
l'urss et les états unis est en train
d'établir ce qu'ils appelaient le nouvel
ordre mondial en faisant la guerre à
saddam hussein en irak et pendant ce
temps là la doctrine néolibérale
s'infiltrer partout et même dans les
universités ont commencé à voir
apparaître qu'on avait jamais vu avant
c'est-à-dire des publicités commerciales
à l'intérieur même des murs de
l'université et pourtant ce qu'on nous
disait ces textes et les féministes et
les antiracistes qui menaçait la liberté
de pensée et qui nous empêcher de lire
les classiques des des doigts et merde
les vieux hommes blancs morts platon
aristote machiavel hobbes rousseau et
marx
j comprenez rien parce qu'en fait depuis
le cégep au bac et la maîtrise qui est
ce que j'avais dû lire en lecture
obligatoire et re lire et relire c'était
platon aristote
machiavel hobbes rousseau et marx et au
début des années 90 le seul pour me
lisez plus en fait c'était marx mais
c'était pas du tout à cause des
féministes et des antiracistes c'est
parce que nos professeurs penser que le
marxisme et sert de plus à rien avec la
chute de l'urss ce qui était évidemment
une erreur
j'ai donc commencé à m'intéresser à ce
discours de panique et de menaces et
j'ai publié un premier tech dans les
années 90 est un autre dans les données
dans les rangs 2001 et j'ai pu contre
confirmer ma conviction que tout ça ce
n'était que de la fumisterie en
poursuivant mes études dans les années
90 au doctorat à l'université de
colombie britannique you be 6 à
vancouver puis-je aller faire un stage
au début des années 2000 postdoctorale
en sciences politiques toujours au
massachusetts institute of technology à
boston em haïti et puis finalement j'ai
été embauché à l'uqam en 2006 en
sciences politiques à l'uqam qui est un
bastion de radicaux comme vous le savez
est donc
en 2022 aujourd'hui à l'uqam en sciences
politiques quels sont les lectures
obligatoires dans nos cours obligatoires
de pensée politique au baccalauréat et
bien tenez vous bien c'est platon
aristote machiavel hobbes rousseau et
marc parce que nous on a récupéré match
parce qu'on est lucas
et donc
est donc vous comprenez bien que nos
étudiants qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
murs de notre université sont curieux
les terres curieusement même pas nés
trente ans plus tôt quand apparemment on
l'a détruisait cette université alors je
suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous dire de
vous méfier d'un certain nombre de sous
discours qui sont liées à cette idée
générale que l'université attaqué par
les féministes et les antiféministes et
les aînés et les aînés et les autres
s'ils réussissent pas bon et donc je
vous dis méfiez-vous premièrement quand
vous entendez que l'université c'était
mieux avant avant les féministes avant
les études de genre avant les études sur
le reste on vous brosse un portrait
d'une université ou des collègues
discuter de manière amicale et collégial
de grandes questions existentielles et
des riffs rechercher ensemble la vérité
le problème avec cette image c'est une
telle université n'a jamais existé quand
les premières universités chrétiennes
ont été fondés en europe au 12e siècle
il y avait des universités dans d'autres
civilisations dont la civilisation
musulmane mais les premières universités
chrétienne fondée en europe au 12e
siècle il y à il ya eu tout de suite des
grèves étudiantes et dans les premières
universités médiévales en italie à
padoue et à bologne par exemple les
étudiants contrôler l université le
recteur et un étudiants et les
professeurs devaient prêter serment au
recteur étudiants les étudiants
pouvaient même suspendre le salaire des
professeurs s'il ne respectait pas le
plan de cours est donc on a des
autorités politiques et religieuses ont
même créé les chairs les fameuses cher
justement pour soustraire les
professeurs à se contrôler étudiants
si on fait un bond de géant au 19è et au
20e siècle qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve dans
les universités en occident on retrouve
en fait des représentants des
différentes idéologies il y a des idées
anarchistes comme un géographe célèbre
elisée reclus il ya des socialistes il
ya des républicains il ya des libéraux
il ya des monarchistes il ya des
catholiques pas pistes les plus grands
universitaires de l'époque utilise les
moyens les plus avancées de la science
pour développer des thèses sexiste et
raciste est justifiée par exemple
l'esclavagisme et le colonialisme on
mesure les en mesure les crânes et on
pèse les cerveaux et devinez quoi quelle
que soit la méthode qu'on utilise on
arrive toujours à la même réponse
c'est les hommes blancs qui sont la
catégorie supérieure de l'humanité c'est
incroyable c'est une chance incroyable
vive la science
dans au 19e siècle qui au xxème siècle
il y a des fois pas toujours pas souvent
mais régulièrement quand même des
étudiants qui perturbe les amphithéâtres
qui perturbe l'enseignement pour des
raisons politiques si le cas de
socialistes révolutionnaires mais aussi
de monarchistes et de catholiques
popiste si bien qu'à la sorbonne par
exemple des enseignements de professeurs
socialistes sont perturbés site si
shalit et que même la police doit
intervenir pour faire évacuer le campus
vous comprenez donc que tout ça ce n'est
pas des nouveautés et que l'idée d'un
campus calme et paisible c'est une
illusion
je vous dis aussi
méfiez vous quand vous entendez que sur
les campus règne un totalitarisme qui
rappelle l'époque de staline ou qui
rappelle la révolution culturelle de mao
c'est un des informations non seulement
ridicule mais abjecte puisque c'est une
insulte à la mémoire des millions et des
millions de personnes qui sont
réellement mort mortes de ces crimes de
masse est en réalité ça ne correspond
évidemment pas du tout à la vie sur les
campus qui est plutôt calme paisible
routinière certains diront même
peut-être ennuyeuse parfois alors que
les professeurs comme moi par exemple
dans le réseau public nous avons des
conventions collectives ou notre liberté
d'expression est assurée y compris par
rapport à la direction on peut critiquer
nos directions plus critiqué le
gouvernement peut critiquer les autres
ce type de convention et ce type de
protection de la liberté d'expression
elle n'a pas d'équivalent dans le
secteur privé est pas non plus dans le
secteur public dire donc on est dans un
système tyrannique ou de censurer tout à
fait ridicule
méfiez vous aussi qu'on vous dit tous
les problèmes viennent des campus
américains des états unis en fait le
réseau universitaire américain il est
immense il y as aimé l'établissement
universitaire aux états unis environ
alors qu'en france en comparaison il y
en a 350 et au québec 19 c'est donc
gigantesque il y a environ un million et
demi de professeur d'université aux
états unis et 20 millions d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes
donc laisser penser que les féministes
et les antiracistes contrôler tout ce
beau monde c'est totalement ridicule
surtout qu'on ne vous dis pas qu'il y à
1700 programme de m billet les master en
business administration
il y à 480 business school donc des
établissements entièrement consacré à
l'enseignement de la gestion et du
commerce il ya à peu près 200
universités qui sont religieuses
chrétiennes catholique ou protestante et
là dedans il y en a 70 qui sont gérés
par les adventistes du septième jour qui
enseigne la théorie créationniste du
début de l'univers je précise que c'est
super ou qu il y à aussi 77 académies
militaires
et 60 programmes en études stratégiques
et sur la guerre dans les universités
privées et publiques donc oui il y a
évidemment les études sur le genre et
des études sur le racisme aux états unis
dans à peu près 5 à 10% des
établissements mais en réalité c'est
très marginal et il ya d'autres forces
beaucoup plus influentes sur les campus
à ce sujet méfiez vous qu'on vous dit à
cause de la can soit culture en anglais
évidemment pour vous faire peur donc la
culture de l'annulation on ne compte
plus les conférences et les aînés est
annulé et les professeurs mises à pied
en réalité il ya des gens qui ont compté
et qu'on compte on réalise que s'il ya
très très peu de cas il ya des cas mais
très peu de cas ces quelques dizaine par
année aux états unis où comme je vous
rappelle il ya un million et demi de
professeurs c'est donc vraiment un des
nombreux minuscule et c'est vrai que des
fois il ya des campagnes de féministes
ou d'antiraciste compte par exemple un
professeur au sujet d'une conférence et
peut-être même qu'elles sont justifiées
parce que peut-être il ya effectivement
des propos racistes ou sexistes
mais en fait c'est une toute petite
minorité et dans les cas les plus les
plus courants les problèmes viennent en
fait de conflit avec la direction au
sujet des règlements par exemple dans
des établissements privés et donc sur
les quelques dizaines de cas de
professeurs sanctionné seulement 25 % à
la fin sont mises à pied et c'est
généralement en raison de conflit avec
leur direction il ya aussi les forces
conservatrices et réactionnaire qui
manoeuvrent contre des professeurs
progressiste vous avez par exemple des
professeurs aux etats unis une
professeure transgenre a été mise à pied
en raison de son identité de genre vous
avez une professeur qui a publiquement
appuyé black light bearer qui a été
envoyée vous avez un proche professeur
qui a ouvertement appuyé le mouvement
anti fasciste il a été renvoyé et
dernièrement à l'université de toronto
une professeure une juriste étrangères
n'a pas été embauché parce qu'une
campagne a été menée contre elle
l'accusant d'être trop proche du
mouvement palestinien est trop critique
envers l'état d'israël et puis enfin il
ya une professeure une théologienne dont
la conférence a été annulée aux états
unis parce qu'elle enseignait la thèse
selon laquelle jésus était queer
et donc les forces conservatrices et
progrès et réactionnaires sont également
bien placés dans les universités pour
nuire aux idées progressistes et à des
collègues progressiste
méfiez vous aussi qu'on vous dit les
études féministes et les études sur le
racisme domine dans les sciences
humaines et sociales et qu'on ne peut
plus être embauchés à l'inversé si on
est un homme blanc je vais vous donner
l'exemple de du québec dans les
universités dans le réseau public au
québec l'universitaire le corps
professoral est composé à 60% d'hommes
donc de ce côté là tout va mieux pour
nous évidemment c'est surtout des femmes
en très grande majorité qui font
fonctionner l'université ce sont les
agentes dans lé secrétariat dans les
services administratifs au registre
arias qui font réellement fonctionné
l'université elles sont presque
uniquement des femmes mais elle n'en
tire que peu de bénéfices et plus de
prestige parlant de précise les fameuses
chaire de recherche là où ce contrôle
des sommes complètement folle d'argent
pour mener de la recherche en sciences
politiques au québec dans les
départements francophone incluant ottawa
il y à 80% de ces chaires de recherche
sont dirigés par des hommes et les
sujets sont tout à fait conventionnel
pour la science politique rien entre web
il y a quatre chaires de recherche en
études stratégiques et sur la guerre
quatre chaires de recherche en
gouvernance et parlementarisme 3 sur les
élections deux ans l'économie politique
et puis ensuite une sur la francophonie
les petites nations une sur le
fédéralisme une sur la psychologie
politique une étude en études
ukrainienne une sur l'afrique du nord et
une en est en étude taïwanaise il y
avait évidemment des études féministes
au québec à l'uqam par exemple mais pas
dans toutes les universités
ça ne représente que 1% des inscriptions
à l'uqam c'est à dire quelques centaines
de personnes sont inscrites en études
féministes au québec en ce en guise de
comparaison à l'uqam l'école des
sciences des sciences de la gestion
recrute 30 % de nos inscriptions c'est
donc tout à fait disproportionnée et un
endroit comme ici où je sais par exemple
on se vante d'avoir 15 mais
l'inscription est d'avoir un programme
orientée spécifiquement pour les cadres
et dirigeants d'entreprises et donc
formé 9000 par année donc vous voyez
encore une fois que l' influence sur les
réseaux universitaires et sur la société
évidemment est totalement démesurée par
rapport à ce qu'on nous présente de l'
influence des études féministes et des
études sur le reste
pour terminer sur une note positive par
rapport à ces champs d'étude qui sont
tellement décriée tellement critiqué et
qu'on prétend qu'ils ont même une force
de destruction non seulement liberté
mais sur la société sur la nation sur la
famille et du terrain
j'aimerais vous rappeler que ces
nouveaux champs d'étude en fait ils
s'inscrivent dans des disciplines très
ancienne rien de très original là dedans
les études féministes ou les études sur
le récif par exemple s'inscrivent en
histoire ou en philosophie ou en
sciences politiques ou en sociologie ou
en histoire de l'art par exemple ils
reprennent leurs méthodes d' enquête
leur méthodologie et peuvent mener donc
des travaux tout à fait rigoureux avec
des bonnes vieilles méthodes éprouvées
ce qui est nouveau ce qui est différent
c'est qu'il pose des nouvelles questions
et selon moi ça devrait être un des
rôles de l'université de poser de
nouvelles questions
c'est pas juste pour nous évidemment que
ces champs d'études ont été développés
mais en fait je pense quand même que par
rapport à moi qui est un homme je ne me
comprends qu'à moitié sans l'aide du
féminisme et en tant que personne
blanche je pense que je ne me comprends
que la moitié sans l'aide des études sur
le récif par exemple et j'en suis
convaincu ces nouveaux champs d'études
sont en fait les principales innovations
et et constituent les principaux axes de
développement des connaissances et le
savoir des trente dernières années on
doit s'en réjouir et je ne peux que vous
encourager à vous y intéresser je vous
remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]